العسكرية الاوكرانية. واضاف ان
الناتو خدع روسيا بتعهداته بعدم
التمدد نحو الشرق ليحاول ضم
اوكرانيا وفق تعبيره. فهل يخفي
الايام ليأتي الدور هنا على
مسيارات موسكو حيث اعلن سلاح
لجيش بلاده على القوات الروسية.
مؤكدا ان هذا الهجوم المضاد يهدف
يملكون فرصا جدية بتحقيق اختراق
خلال الصيف بفضل هجوم مضاد وشيك
المسيرات الايرانية. فكيف سيكون
الحال مع عودة الطائرات الروسية
للعملية ليعلنها رئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني الاسبق نيكولاي ازارو؟
جديدة وذلك وفق تعبيره. ومن
احلام الاوكرانية الى التهديد
احلام اليقظة يا هؤلاء وهنا
تستمر الاحلام الاوكرانية. حيث
ستكون مستعدة للتفاوض مع روسيا
فقط بشروطها الخاصة وقال ان زمن
ازيز الطائرة الاوكرانية يحوم
فوق الكرملين والمبيد الروسي لها
هائل وقال ان روسيا شنته
باستخدام طائرات شاهد ايرانية
روسي. ووصف رئيس الادارة
العسكرية في كييب الهجوم بانه
الصنع فقط بحسب روترز. واذا كانت
كل هذه فوضى والدمار فقط بسبب
صراحة بان الرئيس الينسكي وعد
بجعل اوكرانيا فرنسا او سويسرا
الى العودة الى حدود عام واحد
وتسعين المعترف بها دوليا
والوعيد. ليصرح وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني وليكسرزنيكوف انهم
لاوكرانيا بما يشمل شبه جزيرة
القرد. ليجيب انكم لا زلتم في
صرح ايجور جوفبا نائب مدير مكتب
الرئيس الاوكراني بان اوكرانيا
الدفاع الاوكراني اليكس ريزنيكوف
بان اوكرانيا تسلمت نحو ستين
دبابة لايوبرتو من الغرب واعلن
عن احتياجها لحوالي مائة وعشرين
الجو الاوكراني تدمير اكثر من
عشرين طائرة مسيرة خلال هجوم
بالمرصاد. واوكرانيا تتوعد روسيا
وتحدد اهداف الهجوم المضاد. وبعد
استخباراتي على اعلى مستوى حول
الجزائر ويضم اسرائيل ودولة
الوساطات قد ولى والصين ترفض
اللقاء بالامريكان واجتماع
الناتو يعلن اقتراب ضم السويد.
فماذا عن الرفض التركي ان زمن
الهدنة. مجزرة المسيرات. الحرب
تأخذ منحى اخر لتدخل بذلك جولة
من معارك المسيرات. مخترقة
وعاصمتا روسيا واوكرانيا في مرمى
تمكنت من تدميرها كلها. خرج
المتحدث باسم الكريم ليندم
عربية وعناق مصري تركي حار وفي
السودان الخروقات تعكر صفو
الطيران المسير. وبعد ان اعلنت
وزارة الدفاع الروسية ان كييف
حاولت مهاجمة موسكو بثمن طائرات
مسيرة مؤكدة ان الدفاعات الجوية
وكشف بوتين في تصريحاته عن تدمير
روسيا للمقر الرئيسي للاستخبارات
كييف من خلاله استهداف موسكو
وكذلك استهداف مناطق يؤكد مرة
اخرى ضرورة مواصلة العملية
الخاصة. لتعلن الدفاع الروسي ان
مسيرات بواسطة نظام فانسرس
للصواريخ المضادة للطائرات في
منطقة موسكو وذلك وفق رويترز.
لكن مهلا مهلا فقد حان وقت
بمحاولة ترهيب موسكو من خلال
توجيه ضربات للمراكز السكنية.
ثلاث مسيرات منها تم التصدي لها
عن طريق الدفاعات الالكترونية
وفقدت السيطرة وانحرفت عن
اهدافها المحددة واسقطت خمس
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين ليتكلم.
والذي اتهم كييف في تصريح صحفي
بوتين ما خلف تصريحاته هذه.
معارك المسيرات لا تنتهي هذه
الجديدة الا انه ذهب الى ابعد
الحدود وجعل منها افغانستان
تربيسكوف ليصرح بان الهجوم
بالطائرات المسيرة الذي حاولت
الى انه من الافضل لهذه الدول
عدم تجاوز الخطوط الحمراء فيما
السويد وسويسرا. وتشمل المناورة
مائة وخمسين طائرة في محاولة
وذلك باعلان الخارجية الروسية
استدعاء السفير الفنلندي لدى
موسكو انتي هيلانترا وابلاغه
بقرار تقليص الوجود القنصلي
تولتنبرج في اجتماع لوزراء
خارجية الحلف ان اتخاذ قرار بشأن
يوليو. الاحداث والتطورات. نقلت
صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال عن وزارة
انضمام السويد الى الناتو ممكن
جدا قبل انعقاد قمة فيلنيوس في
الدفاع الامريكية البنتاجون
قولها في بيان جمهورية الصين
الشعبية ابلغت الولايات المتحدة
برفض دعوتنا في اوائل مايو للقاء
بين وزير الدفاع لويد اوستن
ووزير الدفاع الوطني لجمهورية
طائرة مقاتلة. ويجب ان يكون
معظمها من طراز اف ستة عشر وفق
المصري عبدالفتاح السيسي والتركي
رجب طيب اردوجان على البدء
ان الاجتماع ضم اجهزة مخابرات
الكيان الصهيوني والاستخبارات
البلدين. واتفقا على تدعيم اواصر
العلاقات والتعاون بين الجانبين.
انفجار قوي جنوب العاصمة
السودانية الخرطوم مترافقا مع
في ساعات الصباح الاولى بعد
نهاية الهدنة المعلنة في جدة ومع
الصين الشعبية ليشانقو في
سنغافورة الاسبوع المقبل. مضيفة
وذلك لزعزعة الاستقرار في
الجزائر بحسب الصحيفة والتي ذكرت
الفرنسية والمغربية. بانتظار
تعليق السلطات المغربية والتي
الفوري برفع العلاقات
الدبلوماسية وتبادل السفراء بين
تحليق لطائرات حربية مع سماع
لاصوات اسلحة مضادة للطيران ذلك
الى صراع. نقلت صحيفة الخبر
الجزائرية عن مصادر وصفتها
تترك لبلاده اي خيار سوى نشر
اسلحة نووية تكتيكية روسية مشيرا
تضمن الحصانة الدبلوماسية
للمشاركين في اجتماعات وزراء
الوسطاء ومقترحاتهم للازمة
الاوكرانية قد انتهى. فمن اين
تعبيره. برأيكم هل يفعلها الغرب
ويمد اوكرانيا بهذه المقاتلات
استمد جوفبا كل هذه الشجاعة? هل
هناك ايعاز غير ليجيب وزير
بولفوفيتش سكرتير مجلس الامن في
بلاروسيا ان الدول الغربية لم
الجنائية الدولية امرا بتوقيفه.
فهل يحضر بوتين تلك القمة? ومن
وتضم اربع عشرة دولة اثنتا عشرة
دولة عضو في الناتو بالاضافة الى
تعطي حصانة مطلقة لبوتين ليحضر
اليها وذلك بعد ان اصدرت المحكمة
لاستفزاز روسيا بعد الانضمام
للحلس. ياتي الرد الروسي فورا.
تشهد علاقاتها توترا متزايدا في
الفترة الاخيرة. اتفق الرئيسان
التي تعتبرها موسكو ضمن خطوطها
الحمراء؟ لتأتي الاجابة من
المشترك بين البلدين. بينما اكد
الامين العام لحلف الناتو ينس
يتعلق ببعض القضايا الاستراتيجية
الرئيسية. نعم الغرب لم يترك
الخارجية في يونيو وقمة البريكس
في اغسطس وبذلك فان جنوب افريقيا
افريقيا الى احدث عضو في نعم
انها فنلندا والتي اعلنت عن بدء
استضافة عملية تحدي القطب
الشمالي والتي تستمر اسبوعين
بالموثوقة ان اجتماعا مخابراتيا
عقد على اعلى مستوى في اسرائيل.
انها تؤمن ان التواصل المفتوح هو
السبيل لضمان عدو تحول المنافسة
القوانين يا سادة. فلكل فعل ردة
فعل. وهنا اعلن الكسندر
خيارا اخر وهو اعلنت وزارة
الخارجية لجنوب افريقيا عن انها
اكبر المناورات العسكرية حيث
اعلن سلاح الجو الفنلندي عن
الروسي وموسكو ترد على الفور.
وجنوب افريقيا تحصن بوتين وحلف
انضمامها للنايتو فنلندا تجري
اول اجراء عسكري يضايق الدب
بداية لهدنة اخرى.